[Musique]
bonsoir moi c'est j -h je sais pas si
vous savez mais tous les canapés avec
une pastille rouge sont à moins
d'importance tombe donc on fit les
autres avant de lâcher je sais que c'est
un gros investissement je vous laisse le
temps de réfléchir vous inquiétez pas
[Musique]
c'est bon vous inquiétez pas on va
trouver une option de financement on va
dans mon bureau on va regarder ça va
trouver quelque chose
6,8 à quai c'est là qu'est la gela 2011
faut la changer en un jour tu sais les
marches au charbon elle fait des trous
d'un couche d'ozone coin droit de regard
me désole c'est pas moi elle fume pas
elle tous d'où ça vient je ne sais pas
si t'as jamais pensé à faire du stand up
non franchement suit derrière
juste pour vous dire qu'on a fait un
super clip cette semaine et encore bravo
à karim est un genre rigueur j -h
même chose dans ce piège ok comme tu
veux j -h bon appétit
une trottinette
[Musique]
ça va mon coeur
j'ai passé une bonne journée très bien
au lit je me suis battu avec mon patron
je partis à contresens sur périph j'ai
écrasé quelqu'un les flics m'ont arrêté
ils m'ont dit qu'ils allaient ans
arrivant chez toi à moi écoute le
téléphone n'a pas arrêté de sonner
j'ai eu un coup de fil de mark
zuckerberg il m'a commandé une toile en
lieu de lui pour 10 millions de dollars
non il faut se reconstruire
c'est son style sa mark zuckerberg alors
oui c'est lui tu vois pas
donc un petit détail près qu'est-ce qui
manque dit tu veux quelque chose
non mais tu aimes bien qu'à la même
gueule depuis qu'il a 7 ans il a juste
grandi c'est tout tu vois et vous amuser
john f ce branle bas et je crois qu'il a
sa salle à côté c'est pour sa folie du
bâtiment par son décès le stand-up
lasser c'est l'occasion jeu
je peux lui demander des conseils et
tout ça va le déranger une fessée mais
oui vas-y
[Musique]
combien qui a pris une boisson de
personnes âgées bah oui forcément je
savais qu'ils étaient je parle un peu de
ton prix
[Musique]
j'ai une trop bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui
où tu te souviens de resto lapandry là
où je travaillais bon ben j'ai gardé
contact avec la patronne et elle a
accepté de m'exposer pendant quelques
semaines
tétouan oui mes toiles pourquoi donc me
soit elle mérite pas d'être exposé mes
toiles ici bien sûr c'est que je suis
surprise je sais pas si pour être bon
moi je suis content pour toi c'est très
bien c'est juste que voilà je rentre
j'ai la tête comme ça tu enchaînes voilà
en ce moment pour l'achat d'un canapé 3
places de plus recevez un fauteuil kiwi
gratuitement profitez-en
[Musique]
car ça t'a surprise ouais c'est cool non
on va voir en fait de stand up tu
connais il ya plein de maurice qui sont
chers à jamais entendu parler non non
juste m2 près par hasard non non mais
pas du tout c'est pas beau de mettre la
pression mais c'est juste que voilà
c'est trop pas de mal de rire un petit
peu oui tu as raison mais c'est une
super surprise
merci bonsoir les comédies choqué ça va
super vous allez passer un excellent
moment on a sélectionné des artistes
formidables
on va commencer par la première vous
êtes prêts faites du bruit pour giuly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si les primes aux biens
je te montrerai ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à accueillir
le prochain
c'est la première fois qu'il ya ici donc
je compte sur vous pour l'accueillir
chaleureusement fait du bruit pour jim
mesdames et messieurs
[Musique]
bonsoir merci yacine même si je suis
déjà venu dix fois à peu près séparation
je n'aime pas ce mec je me présente je
m'appelle j'y vois là et avant d'être
humoriste j'avais un autre métier je
sauvais des gens j'étais vendeur de
canapé j'ai arrêté ce métier le jour je
me suis dit tu sais ce qui est bien est
un revendeur de cannabis et que j'ai pas
réussi à terminer cette phrase dans mon
ancien métier avait quand même un petit
avantage
[Musique]
voilà c'est tout pour moi fait du bruit
pour le prochain
[Applaudissements]
pardon je suis désolé ce train un coup
de philippe argent tu vas où c'est hyper
compliqué à expliquer tu veux tu va aux
toilettes
ouais voilà ouais ok mais c'est
compliqué a expliqué toujours les
regards mais qu on se ressemble
comme deux gouttes d'eau c'est ouf je
comprends pas merde quoi
on a la même voix en plus t'en vas y dis
quelque chose pour voir toilettes
japonaises
c'est fou quand tu t'appelles moi c'est
dit et toi moi tout le monde m'appelle
j'y h tu t'appelles jean-hugues comment
tu sais non mais c'est moi j'en rigole
en fait j c'est un nom de scène ce que
je peux pas ça qui est mon prénom 28
hockey aujourd'hui c'est ton
anniversaire tenais angoulême parents
divorcés mère au foyer père
experts-comptables j'enfile grand phare
qui t'a mis la misère quand tu étais
jeune et qui a repris l'activité du
d'annoncer ça
[Musique]
j'avais un poster de jessica alba au
dessus de son lit quand était ado tu
t'es beaucoup prend l'air le regardant
non non ça ne s'annonce à me dire oh
mec est exactement la même
personne sauf que moi je me suis branler
de ouf regardant escale en fait si la
branlette du scalp à 6,6 et ça m'emmerde
j'ai fait les saluer sur scène pour tout
le monde soit là ouais j'y arriverai
attendre la sortie d'accord j'ai acheté
là je suis désolé j'ai pas testé un cas
vraiment trop dans le mal ok ça fait
larguer par son mec je pouvais pas la
laisser tout seul but donc bah je vais y
aller
ok ok tu m'en veut pas ou non non je
bats je suis désolé je rentre après le
spectacle on dit mais je te dis quand je
rentre
c'est fou
je pensais que je venais de rêver mais
non existent vraiment temer elle pense
vraiment qu'on trouve une explication on
peut exploser les chez moi si tu veux
enfin chez nous ta vie toujours un
cliché bah oui à toi non je déménage et
moi ok on est des jumeaux séparés à la
naissance
non c'est pas possible on a la même vie
ou alors témoin du passé et moi je viens
pour te prévenir que dans le futur il ya
un spécial non non j'ai pensé c'est pas
possible tu as bien trente ans
aujourd'hui
ouais bah voilà on a le même âge tu peux
pas venir du futur ah c'est vrai
et les plus vendeurs alors non je me
suis lancé à fond dans le stand up c'est
jamel qui m'a conseillé de trouver du
temps pour me lancer pour être mon
spectacle tu connais jamel ouais j'ai
rencontré par hasard à l'anniversaire de
type et c'est pokémon et du coup je suis
allé le voir
tu risques ce qui m'a dérangé tu penses
que tu aurais des conseils pour
quelqu'un qui veut se lancer dans le
stand-up
je suis demandé des conseils m'a donné
surtout beaucoup de contacts pour
m'entraîner pour fermer les scènes
partout pas ce mardi peut-être que je
pense que je vais habiter un grave
[Musique]
en fait c'est là où nos vies sont
différentes c'est pas mon mois du futur
ou je sais pas quoi
j étais à l'anniversaire de steam j'ai
croisé jamel sauf que on n'a pas discuté
pourquoi bah il est passé vite j'ai pas
le temps paris est occupée proposez quoi
non mais c'est jusqu'en fin j'avais pas
le déranger et puis j'avais peur enfin
peut-être que je me trouvais drôle ou
que j'ai pas je prends trop la tête
franchement moi j'y suis allé pour ça
que j'étais hyper stressée en fait et le
stand-up ça marche
cependant pour moi ouais carrément
écoute je fais pas mal de premières
parties
j'ai un petit spectacle qui se construit
comme ça et surtout j'ai eu un passage à
la télévision
il ya eu des extraits sur youtube ces
cartes under mec je trouve plus mes
sketches sur youtube
j'existe opus sur internet jy les
mariages 2 millions de vues sur youtube
ci ou ça j'étais venu dans ma dimension
où trouver un moyen pour que tu rentres
chez toi que c'est cool de revenir et je
vais ouvrir ses patins bien tu as tes
chaussures
[Applaudissements]
ouais
oh
ok au choix plus tard a fait des petits
cachottiers voix
merci pour la surprise un branchement
c'est fou dit rien de changé ouais ouais
pour faire plus propre quoi tu t'en
étais pas
non gérés a vu mieux je pense qu'il ya
des retardataires bougez pas je reviens
ok on est encore avec les là et ce
moment là j'ai vu parler et tu peux pas
tu peux pas parce que tu es triste pas
ici tu comprends ça on serait demain
d'accord et j'ai lu paroisse léger pas
ta partie si tu vas chez maintenant qu
est donc en marche semble pas du tout
d'accord c'était une erreur
on va mettre bonne musique à merci
d'être là en tout cas ça me fait super
plaisir vraiment
désolé j'ai des preuves de transparence
à l'adversaire parfait
t'as qu'à te mandela je regarde
[Musique]
c'est bon
bon
coco
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
sur les chaloupes un discours est ce qu
a dit merci d'être là tous
[Musique]
ok c'était un beau discours de mr
d'aller à ta santé hhs cette chanson va
pas bouger en disant merci
un dégât des eaux le jour de son
anniversaire ouais non mais c'est juste
de l'eau qui coule dans la chambre d'à
quel point ce serait vite réglé il y là
les là elle est chez ses parents
d'accord désolé d'avoir des revenus
comme ça font plus rien moment suis
content de t'avoir à la maison
sylvie sarthe est patent l'habitude de
différent tu vas te coucher parce que
demain au magasin peut être fatiguée si
maman est ce que tu crois au monde
parallèle
comment est filmé dans six mois laissons
ça me rappelle je t'aime et 30 ans
c'était une journée bien particulière ou
buts soit tu me croirais pas allez bonne
nuit
et karine ça fait longtemps qu hier
ah ah oui tu es toujours là faut qu'on
se parle et moi il faut que je travaille
je veux pas qu'on soit à l'heure plutôt
écoute je crois c'est déjà arrivé à
maman et je pense que je suis dans ton
monde que pour 24 heures et ce soir je
serai plus là c'est vrai tu dois te
soulager l'or mais non mais du coup tu
dois te lancer ce soir
non non non non tu attends je suis pas
prêt moi je vais commencer ce soir c'est
pas possible j'ai pas de tête j'ai rien
je vais te coach et ce soir tu montes
sur scène après je peux plus là tu me
fais confiance
oui allô slim way s'est dit ça va cj h
pardon mais on se connaît pas nos dix
mois j'ai eu des contacts par yacine et
est ce que tu as une place de libre sur
le plateau de ce soir tout hasard bah
ouais c'était cool
ouais j'ai de l'expérience j'ai changé
non je n'ai pas d'expérience après fois
que je fais ça parole je suis un mec
hyper drôle de mec le plus drôle de la
région parisienne voit la super ok bah
ce soir alors merci la bise à sarah je
me ferai jamais c'est bon pour ce soir
au quai par angie j'ai rien préparé et
au courant de ça donc faut que tu me
files débat non non ça c'est du plagiat
sa bannette evans aimé van tu vas pas
faire ton copie comme non non ça c'est
du plagiat autre dimension celle du
clash je me prendre un beat c'est sûr
red moi je te plaît t'inquiète à noter
plein de vannes dans ton téléphone
non si non je jure de rien aux mecs toi
c moi je peux pas me douillet qu'est ce
que je peux de combat bon allez on y va
je fais quoi battus raconté van tu vois
et moi je te coach je te dis comment
faire ok sauf la vanne sur la fête
foraine
sabine à chaque fois je les fais trois
fois sur scène ça marche pas je vois
pourquoi allez ciao hockey l'esclavagé a
été aboli en france pourtant je me
souviens avoir été stagiaire
ok ça c'est de la merde le thème des
stagiaires c'est super mais juste tu vas
trop vite un prends ton temps tu es
stressé tu déballe tout comme ça tu
inquiète on a le temps j'ai compris
djebbour isaba l'esclavagé a été aboli
en france pourtant je me souviens avoir
été stagiaire
ok c'est mieux mais la posture déjà ça
va pas du tout lâché pas tiens bien ton
micro déjà et puis je sais pas et la
relaxe voilà c'est de la merde pas du
tout
[Musique]
jusqu'au
jean-yves ghd moi ça et qui tu parles
depuis ce matin action
[Musique]
un gros cube je rentre à lui faire
acheter tout magasin un chiffre
d'affaires de coup d'état
franchement merci c'est sympa de ma part
sympa de sa part c'est pas mal ça allait
tout cela en plus cacahuètes c'est bon
ça bonne idée bah ouais même goût ça va
caïla je suis pas je me demande si on
n'a peut-être pas besoin de nouveau
c'est quand j'ai commencé le stand up
moi si j'avais besoin de nouveaux alors
j'ai tout quitté le champ parties à zéro
mais je sais pas si c'est le poids de
mon ancienne vie qui s'est volatisé trop
d'un coup mais j'étais très arrogant
mais on a voulu et c'est normal j'étais
un gros coup alors elle a pris ses
affaires
elle est partie à l'étranger elle
actuellement je pense qu'elle est dans
un petit deux pièces où la face cachée
de la lune bien loin de moi les semaines
passent et voilà tout se passe bien
sauf qu'au bout d'un moment à chaque
fois que je monte sur scène je pense à
elle
et pensez à son aise quand tu fais des
blagues
mais c'est cool je me fais d'études je
rencontre du monde faire des gens mais
je fais pas rire la bonne personne je
sais c'est dur quand tu descends de
seine était temps qu'une chose c'est la
croisée mais mais non la dernière image
quota de leïla c'est l ampleur en train
d'insulter après peut-être qu'on n'est
pas exactement pareil vous sandwich pour
les cacahuètes
on est les salaires chez saab l'an je
sais je sais exactement où tu en es tu
es perdu parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé sa
place et moi je te dis notre place ce
avec les la bon donnes tout ce que tu as
ce soir non mais tu vas où je suis pas
prêt pour ce soir moi t'inquiète pas
toujours été prêt
et je bouge ça comment moi
[Musique]
alors j'ai revendu quoi le gros clients
à rien en fait je voulais acheter une
voiture droit cha
[Musique]
lüthi second numéro
patron je vais partir plus tôt
aujourd'hui j'ai partir maintenant en
fait même
[Musique]
ça va tu m'en contente toi t'es bizarre
ok ce que je veux dire est très
important pour moi d'accord ok je suis
désolé je suis désolé mais j'ai
complètement merdé
je comprends qu'ils soient partis loin
que tu veux plus voir la gueule je
comprend de quoi tu parles tu saches que
tu est la personne la plus incroyable
que je connaisse j'aime ta manière de
vivre de voir le monde
j'aime quand tu acceptes les différences
gmt peinture j'aime j'aime ton sourire
si tu comprends pas ce que je te dis
jamais tu m'as la banque compte de la
chance que j'ai d'avoir à mes côtés
ce soir je vais faire de trucs un petit
peu fou d'abord je suis monté sur scène
pour la première fois de ma vie
j'aimerais qu'il soit là c'est vrai
c'est génial bien sûr que je serai là et
c'est quoi le truc je regarde
qu'est ce que tu fous tu dois pas être
accueil à toi fallait vraiment que je
vois une dernière fois tu fais quoi là
vraiment ça à ton tour montre tout quoi
g
ce que tu m'épouser
un maximum en scène il s'appelle gilles
vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je m'appelle jean hugues j'ai
pas choisi ce prénom
je trouve que jean luc c'est pas un
prénom que tu donnes à un bébé je pense
que ma mère elle voulait directement
accouché d'un expert comptable de 60 ans
c'est pas un prénom que je vis très bien
quand j'étais au collège par exemple ont
été que deux à s'appeler comme ça
c'était moi et le proviseur
le proviseur je croisais dans les
couloirs il faisait des et moi je
faisais des j'ai quand même demandé à ma
mère pourquoi elle a voulu cacher a dit
mais tu as vu leur toit mais au mois
prévient droit quant au retard
patron je voulais vous prévenir d'autres
choses je démissionne quoi
mais tu vas où là j'ai un spectacle à
écrire cela
mais j -h zinc
[Musique]
oh merde tu t'es lancé dans le stand-up
oh
[Musique]
et